I recently did a video discussing the
post-credits scene of ant-man in the
wasp whilst it was predominantly
speculation since the film's release it
has been proven to be correct throughout
this video I'll be discussing my theory
on where this leaves ant-man and what
will happen in the future to correct the
predicament that he now finds himself in
there are huge spoilers for both ant-man
and the wasp and infinity war throughout
this video so it may be best to give
this a Miss if you still want to see
them fresh with that out the way I'm
definition and this is my theory for the
post-credits scenes of a man in the wasp
in the post-credits scene Pym and Janet
create a smaller version of the quantum
Rampal all that fits in the back of
Louise's van sending Scott in to collect
quantum particles they warn him of the
dangers of time vortexes stating that
should he become lost in one they will
be unable to get him out and he then
continues his mission once Scott has
finished he asks to be brought back
through the portal but things go awry
when there's no response
Scott is unable to return and become
stuck in the quantum realm and the final
shot of the scene cut to the location
where Scott set off where we discover
that Pym Janet and help have vanished
there's a faint shimmer of dust in the
wind signifying that darkness is snap
has ruled them all out of existence
this leaves Scott completely stranded in
the dimension but we have seen from
folklore leaks of Avengers for that
ant-man joins the team in their quest to
regain the Infinity stones so he must
escape i theorize that you will be aided
by Captain Marvel who may have been
stuck in a time vortex which will
explain why her character has not aged
from her origin film which is say the
90s her return through the quantum realm
would allow her to rejoin Scott and then
free him from the dimension Carol
Danvers which is the alter ego of
Captain Marvel possesses superhuman
strength endurance stamina flight
physical durability a limited
precognitive Sixth Sense and it
perfectly amalgamated human slash Kree
physiology which renders her resistant
to most toxins and poison as binary the
character can tap the energy of a white
hole allowing full control
manipulation of stellar energies and
therefore control over heat the
electromagnetic spectrum and gravity
this showcases that she is more than
capable to leave the dimension and will
ideally bring Han man along with her
I've seen some theory state that dr.
strange also has access to the quantum
realm so he may be able to free Scott
however he was wiped out by Dennis's
snap so unless he returns before freeing
ant-man
it seems unlikely other possible
conclusions are that Scott gets trapped
in a time vortex and this sends him back
into the past Wei is able to rejoin the
Avengers as they return to the Battle of
New York so what are your theories on
the post-credits scene about man in the
wasp do you have an even better one
comment below and let me know as I'd
love to hear your thoughts if you
enjoyed this video please like it and
subscribe to my channel to keep up to
date with all movie and Marvel news make
sure you check out my full ant-man and
the wasp post-credit scene breakdown at
the end of this one thanks very much for
taking the time to watch this video I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]